hey everyone and welcome back to the
beginner to master run episode number
22 uh have a fun one in episode 21 a lot
of interesting games I was in trouble in
uh the last game I played but managed to
get out of it so currently on a 73 game
win streak rated 1183 so maybe I can
break 1,200 in this
episode uh let's just hop into
it playing Mari who is also trying to
break 1200 rated
1199 and still staying with the same
opening
repertoire um at some point I will
probably start mixing up the openings
but um yeah still following basic
principles controlling the center
defending the
pawn uh we've seen a mix of different
openings that White's played in this
series D4 is the scotch I'll take the
pawn taking is really the only good move
otherwise White will build up the space
and here there's a couple moves uh
Knight F6 and Bishop C5 are the two most
common moves by far uh some players make
the mistake of taking which just allows
white to dominate the center with the
queen so I'll play Bishop C5 here simply
developing and attacking the Knight
again and after Bishop
E3 uh White is threatening to take which
would win material because my Bishop on
C5 is not defended
uh so the best move here is actually to
play Queen
F6 and there's a lot of openings where
you shouldn't develop the queen early
but this is an exception to that rule or
the queen uh helps pressure various
points in White's position white
defended the Knight with
C3 and I think from here I'll keep
developing uh Knight
G7 um because the Queen's taking F6
Square the Knight can develop here uh
reinforcing this Knight and now if Tak
on C6 the knight's not actually hitting
the queen so I could then take on
E3 um but white plays Queen
D2 a solid looking move and I played
this opening a lot from the black side
growing up also occasionally from the
white side but I don't actually know
like so much specific Theory
here uh so I think I'll just be
following basic principles I do want to
keep an eye out for Bishop G5 but then I
have Queen G6 and the queen should be
very fine there uh so let's go ahead and
Castle I guess now I should note that if
takes then I don't want to take on E3
because then white could take with
check and I would be losing a piece in
that line because white would then take
back so if takes here the queen can take
and defend the
bishop um very important to make sure
that uh I'm not losing material in in
White's forcing
lines so generally white should develop
this bishop and look to Castle King side
uh the bishop has a choice between a few
options uh but Bishop D3 might leave the
Knight less
defended um because it would obstruct
the
queen so probably anticipating Bishop E2
or Bishop C4
here but of course there's other moves I
mean we might see Bishop G5 or Knight
takes
C6 so the ball is in White's
Court we see Bishop C4 yeah this is a
more active move uh of course aligning
with my
king now it is a question how I want to
complete
development um there's cases where black
likes to get in D5 right
away um D5 in this
position I think just loses a pawn so
now not a move I really want to spend
too much time on uh D6 is probably the
most natural move to open the
bishop there's also a move like Knight
E5 to centralize and attack this
bishop
so I'll take a moment
here I kind of like the idea of Knight
E5 right away cuz then there's ideas of
Knight G4 and maybe maybe it gets a
little bit awkward for white with a
bishop on
E3 I guess I should also note here that
I could consider this move to attack
both
pawns uh but then I guess F3 would
defend defending E4 and defending G2
with the
queen so I mean a lot of fine options
I'm going to go for Knight E5 though
this looks to be one of the more
aggressive
approaches see what white wants to do
with this B Bishop I mean maybe the
bishop should move back to save it or
save the bishop and also prevent Knight
to
G4 and if we see this then I'll probably
continue with
D6 um also supporting
G4 I mean very often when a bishop is
developed E3 this knight move could
cause some
troubles but white uh not defending but
rather
counterattacking so my queen is hit
and there's a few options here I could
consider taking the bishop probably the
first move I should look
at might get messy because after Bishop
takes F6 Knight takes
D2 Bishop takes
E7 have to keep track of the material
situation I would have Knight takes B1
in that
line but after Bishop takes
C5 it's kind of a long sequence where I
think at the end my knight is going to
be trapped and
don't think black is for Choice there
but I should also I mean I should look
at the branches so takes takes
takes
takes I could take back white will take
back and it's a fair trade where I'll
have two Bishops against two knights in
a way more simplified
position
so yeah I think taking is is very
playable I mean I could also move here
and the knight's still defended by the
bishop I guess do I want to keep the
tension or do I want to go for trades
and liquidate a little
bit um time is running a bit low
realizing that after this move I'm still
attacking the
bishop and I'm attacking the pawn I mean
E4 and G2 are still
undefended
it's kind of hard to calculate because
yeah white might have a few moves in
response but
intuitively I think I like this move
better just
because my my position is a bit more
solid and White's position just looks
very vulnerable um like even this bishop
it's defended by the queen if white
plays a move like Bishop D3 to defend
the pawn then the queen would be
overworked defending two Bishops I can
take on D3 and then take on
G5 so it's possible I'll be winning
material
here we see Bishop to
B3 saving the bishop allowing me to take
the pawn with
chck and yeah I do have to be careful
with my
queen just smacking the center but it's
doing a lot of damage to White's
position and uh also attacking the pawn
on
G2 so maybe we'll see King F1 I mean
sometimes these positions just get sharp
very quickly I mean this
opening uh features the early tension
where there's uh the early fireworks so
trying to get the better of white here
uh Queen E2 is
played so I could take which leaves a
knight undefended but attacks a
rook also attacks a
bishop
now I also have Knight D3 here which
will force the king to move because the
queen is
pinned I think after Knight D3 King F1
that only helps
white I think I'm much better off taking
on G2 it's a crazy position a lot of
things are
attacked but again I think uh I'm
getting the better of the craziness
here
and if white takes either Knight I can
start by taking with chck a going up
material and if we see Rook F1 then I
can take the
bishop so yeah not sure what to expect
here from
White I've already taken a lot of time
taken more more than half my time 11
moves in but mean sometimes when things
get complicated from early on you do
want to invest the time to uh come up
with the Right
Moves so we'll be having to move a
little bit quicker going
forward we see Queen
F1 so yeah this is a good sign I can
take the bishop going up
material and now there's really no
worries in the position some idea of
Queen C1 I guess the only small worry is
F4 is is a fork but then uh there' be a
few options F4 maybe I could take on F4
and then Knight
G3 eventually with a counter
Fork but
here okay Knight D3 Knight D3 is
interesting because the queen is tied
down to the Rook but there's also Queen
C1 which looks very
powerful I'm going to go for Queen
C1 attacking the king attacking
B2 white has two legal moves here Bishop
D1 or King
E2 and now I can take a pawn with check
attacking The Rook white can save The
Rook with Knight
C2 blocking the check and defending or
Knight D2 okay defending with the
queen um I guess a drawback of Knight D2
is it leaves C3
undefended but do I want to take on
C3 I still have to watch out for White's
alignment against my king for now it's
not a huge
concern I think I'm more inclined to
take the Knight
first and then after takes I can take on
D4 centralize a
queen um maybe we'll see Queen G2
threatening
checkmates but then there will be ways
to to
cope um something like Knight
G6
and the strategy going forward from here
is to start exploiting the king try and
get the rest of the pieces into play and
the Knight would like to come to F4 Rook
would like to come to E8 even the bishop
can come
in but uh yeah first things first let's
not get
checkmated Knight is a Defender would
very soon like to be an attacker
threatening n
for
and okay this is interesting because I
can start with Knight
F4 I think I
will very important that this is check
otherwise I I would lose the game
instantly and yeah white just
resigns um I mean if white played I
guess the only legal moves Were King
here here then I was ready to take the
Rook with chck and then eventually
regain the or just win the queen or uh
or go for some Ming attack so okay um
very sharp game from early on uh
hopefully there's some lessons to take
away I mean with this opening it's very
possible for black to get in trouble
early on if if Black's not accurate
maybe Queen D2 was a little bit slow uh
I think the the main lines are either
Bishop C4 or Bishop E2 and then usually
white should Castle as quickly as
possible so G2 is
defended but what happened the
game uh like once I played Knight E5 and
then I think Bishop G5 was actually the
blunder allowing me to get just a lot of
a lot of attacks and yeah there's no
easy way for white to defend everything
here so nice game to start the episode
nice way to show how to take down the
scotch opening from early on so let's
keep it going rated
1191 uh another 10-minute game playing
Tek from
Canada and I'll go for
E4 and we have a
kocan um I'm going to go for the two
Knight's attack which is one of my
favorite weapons against the carocon I I
played this a few episodes ago I made a
whole video about this opening a few
years ago which I will link below uh D4
is one of the more aggressive moves
which gains space early gains time on
this
Knight and I'll be moving this knight uh
for the third time in the first five
moves uh but one of the points of of
going for this from the white side is
the knights are generally pretty happy
here they can be attackers later in the
middle game they can also help keep my
king side very safe uh with Bishop G4
this is a uh pin but I don't really have
to go for H3 right away uh the move I'm
going to go for here is Bishop to
C4 and this is setting up tactics
involving Bishop takes F7 and then
Knight E5 or
G5 which black very smartly prevents uh
E6 creating the pawn chain against the
bishop so yeah unfortunately I won't
have any like oh no my queen tactics in
in this game at least most likely but I
can keep
developing uh there's D3 3 there's
castling there's
H3 I don't think it makes a huge
difference which move I play first I'll
start with D3 getting ready to develop
my final minor
piece and yeah pretty soon I I'll
probably go for
H3 which should induce the trade on
F3 and it is nice kind of forcing this
piece off the board early on can
activate the Queen the queen is very
happy here uh there's already a lot of
pieces in my position aimed towards
Black's King side so if black Castle
King side I think there will be a lot of
attacking
potential now in going forward I still
probably want to Castle King
side and there's cases where even if I
Castle King side I can still attack on
that side later on and black castles so
showing showing no fear
and yeah I'm definitely um inclined to
try and orchestrate some sort of
kingside attack I mean moves like Bishop
G5 or Knight H5 come to mind also
something like E5 which would remove the
Knight unleash the queen uh E5 would run
into Knight D5 so I'm not sure if I want
to give back the
square take a moment to consider my
options uh another idea is to somehow
move my Queen off the f file so I can
get my Pawn rolling with
F4 it's very nice to to expand with F4
and then later F5 so the bishop and Rook
can play a
role uh and maybe the way to do that is
to start with Knight H5 offer the Knight
trade and my queen lands on H5 then the
pawn can start rolling I think I prefer
that more than Bishop G5 like even
though Bishop G5 it's developing the
final minor piece after move like H6 I
don't really think I want to trade that
off and it's kind of awkward moving back
where it's kind of fighting for the G3
square with a
knight so I'm going to go for Knight
H5 yeah just offering the trade to
Knights trying to remove one of the main
Defenders on Black's King
side and if black doesn't take your
right away then uh yeah then maybe I can
take and put the queen on
G3 and then still go for
expansion black is going
for
B5 so I mean if I want to I could play
A4 I could also just allow it and drop
the bishop back eventually I'm trying to
imagine a scenario where I allow B5 and
then get in this move maybe with
inclusion of
taking but
um I don't think I want to overthink
things so I'm just going to go ahead and
take
First expecting Bishop
takes and yeah I want to play Queen
G3 but I also don't really want to give
black the opportunity to play B5 and
then maybe later prepare C4
so I'm going to start with A4 here uh
very simple preventive move it's very
common uh to do this when the opponent
is threatening to expand just to slow
them down uh Knight C6 makes sense
developing threatening Knight E5 to work
the queen and Bishop so let's slide over
to
G3 I mean so far this is a very solid
game from both
sides black has really done nothing
wrong and is exerting pressure now on
the queen side so now I should probably
just Retreat like there's really no
other way to defend the pawn other than
Bishop
B3 and this move might allow black to
play
B5 and B5 will lead to
some uh some trades potentially with
pawns and
Rooks I'm still looking to consider
ideas like E5 an
F4 also Bishop H6 in the the near
future so we see Rook
C8 yeah it looks like black is preparing
B5 and then wants to get in a quick
C4 so there's a few options I could play
A5 to really clamp down and then at B5
there's
aant or I could go for my own play on
the king side
if I play a move like
E5 um I mean if the bishop moves back to
E7 then I have Bishop H6 looks like that
would win material because black would
have to play G6 and I win The
Rook so I'm thinking that after E5 black
will have to play Bishop
H4 then I play Queen
G4 I'm trying to determine if it's worth
committing the pawn here I think it is
though cuz then yeah The Bishop's going
to still be a Target I'll be threatening
Bishop
H6 and a move like F5 leaves this Pawn
hanging let's go for
E5 um slight change in plans my original
plan was to play F4
F5 but I'm liking this move because it's
removing the Bishop from its defensive
Square on
F6 and yeah once it moves away then G G7
is going to be a bit more
vulnerable okay the bishop moves back
very quickly and now I can get in Bishop
H6 so now it looks like yeah black has
to play
G6 I'm not sure if I even want to take
the Rook Bishop is really nice here uh
but I probably do because if I allow
Rook E8 then black will be looking to
play Bishop
f8 so let's go ahead and
take I do have to watch my
time but uh yeah nice Victory winning
material in the middle game and now
let's keep expanding I'm going to go for
F4
here still looking to get this break in
because this this Pawn break is a move
that would
favor or make the bishop and Rook
happier um I'm trying to exploit the
fact that g Pawn is pinned but here I
have to watch out for Knight E3 with a
fork so let's just
trade happy to remove the
Knight and
now I'm going to play Pawn
B3 trying to just ensure that black is
not creating any issues on the queen
side with C4
break so some prophylactic pawn moves on
the queen
side and yeah the pine going forward is
to really focus on the king side
ideally put the Rook probably on E1 and
then either go for F5
immediately assuming I maintain the pin
or gradually build up with moving the
queen and then G4
F5 so yeah looks like everything is
under
control Fox still goes for C4 so this is
a pawn
sacrifice um I'm taking it I mean this
is really the reason why I played B3 is
to ensure that I can take a Pawn on
C4 and this is open the file for The
Rook which yeah let's put the Rook on
the half open file targeting the pawn on
B7 and this is actually a nice reason to
have double pawns so I have the the file
to work with for The
Rook black defends so it's not going to
be easy to to win the pawn on that
file F5 would lose this Pawn so let's go
for some more gradual Improvement Queen
F3 uh maybe looking to play Queen B7
which would basically be a triple attack
attacking the two pawns and The
Rook back is leaving the B Pawn
undefended but attacking my a
pawn yeah let's go for Queen B7 triple
attack
attack back is going to have to save The
Rook here and then then I'll have a
choice which Pawn to
capture uh probably the a pawn first to
defend this
Pawn I guess I could have taken here to
attack The Rook as
well but yeah looking to take your next
move Bishop
B4 this does obstruct The Rook but now
it's walking into Queen takes
B6 just cleaning up the queen side
attacking the bishop and The Rook there
is a move here for vck to save both
pieces I think the only move is Bishop
to
E7 now yeah things are looking very good
uh I'm very close to trapping the queen
like Rook A1 doesn't quite trap the
queen though because there's Queen
C3 so I think from here I just want to
push the pawn and not get too low on
time this is now a pass
pawn
and probably very soon I can move the
Rook to A1 to support the
[Music]
pawn and it's very difficult for black
to generate any counterplay although C2
is
undefended
so am I okay with losing it
I think what they'll do here is just
Counterattack Queen C7 attacking the
bishop The Bishop's tied down to
defending the rook and I'm happy to
abandon the pawn if I'm winning one of
Black's pieces
here okay Bishop H4 that's a resourceful
move maybe looking to come in and
holding on to The
Rook um I'm wondering if I can just play
G3
it looks weakening
but there's really no way for black to
immediately exploit my
king and if Bishop takes
G3 oh that's um that's a move Black's
looking to check but now I can take the
bishop and even if black gets in this
move something like King
G2 there's enough uh enough things
around the king to prevent any Perpetual
check like Queen E2 Rook
F2 the checks should run
out now now now the queen is attacked
The Rook is still attacked there's no
Queen G4 check so yeah G3 was a nice way
to basically dominate the bishop there
is nowhere safe to move it and black
black is trying their best but now the
position is
crumbling King moves back I'll have
checkmate if the king moves
forward okay if the king moves forward I
didn't see an immediate mate but
something like Queen G5 would uh would
simplify so I think that was a pretty
smooth game um hopefully a nice
demonstration of how to play such a
structure from the two knights attack
against the kocan especially when black
pushes because black did grab space in
the center but I got some very nice
harmony with the pieces I mean the setup
is very solid where pretty much every
minor piece for white has a nice
square and then later in the middle game
um was able to slow down Block's play
while accelerating my play on the king
side E5 I think was nice to drive the
bishop away and then eventually win
material and the conversion was pretty
smooth as
well so okay um let's move on let's do
at least one more game rated
1197 uh hopefully it will just take one
more to break 1200 here we go playing
Andreas and this time I'm playing the
white side of a King's
Pawn and I'll play Bishop
C4 standard Italian Italian Geo piano
this has a few
names black playing very quickly so I
think I'll go for um the Greco Gambit
which is starting with
D4 it's an opening I played a few
episodes ago and it's an opening that I
learned very early on in my childhood
blacks playing all the main
moves although Bishop takes is
not the most common uh usually it's
Knight takes
E4 so we'll see what black is up to here
uh not trying to take the pawn but
rather
castling so going forward from here I
think it's already an opening success
cuz I have the bishop hair I have the
center pawns and I can grab
space um I don't think I want a castle
and a laac to take so let's go forward
just attacking the
Knight I mean if Queen E7 or Rook E8 to
pin the pawn then I'll very simply
castle unpinning and attacking the
Knight
and with Knight
D5 yeah black is attacking the C3
Pawn I'm wondering if it's possible to
like try and trap the Knight
here Bishop D5 is is not quite working
because Knight takes
C3 but um yeah there might be some
tactics with a knight undefended so see
what the other options are queen D3 or
queen
C2 even a move like Bishop
D3 I mean Bishop D3 is perhaps a fancy
option where if Knight
takes then I can look to play Queen C2
attacking and creating the battery
against
H7 I'm thinking whatever I do to attack
the knights whether it be moving the
queen or Bishop black can then play
D5
so something like Queen C2
D5 attacking and defending I can a
assant black can take
back not sure how much I'm getting
there I mean Bishop
D3 maybe is a bit preferable over Queen
C2 because that way I I really like the
bishop aimed at uh at H7 yeah let's
let's start with this and then if D5
after takes takes there's no more Bishop
on C4 that will hit uh or that will get
hit by the knight uh but black goes for
Knight takes C3 so snagging the pawn and
now I do have a choice here like I was
initially considering Queen C2 to attack
and also attack
H7 but there's another option to start
with Bishop takes H7
which will either win back the Knight
assuming King takes or after takes
takes there's perhaps a more ambitious
move Knight
G5 and this is basically a Greek gift
where if the King goes back then I have
Queen
H5 uh Greek gift is exactly the sequence
where you sack on H7 with the bishop get
the Knight and Queen in and black might
be defenseless in that position
so yeah let's go for
this and worst case if for some reason
I'm overlooking something I can always
uh choose to win back the
Knight I guess P could consider King
h8 oh but one thing I'm missing yeah
speaking of worst case
scenario
uh yeah I I saw Knight G5 King moves but
the king doesn't have to move if I play
Knight G5 the queen can take
and this was a bit of a blind spot
because okay I assume just Bishop takes
but my queen is also
hanging so I don't think this actually
works like
takes on
G5 if I play Queen D3 to save my queen
and check the
king black can then save their own Queen
getting out of the
attack it's a big mess though cuz then I
can win back back then I lost a knight
I've already sacked a bishop
too yeah I think I'm just better off
winning the
Knight it is nice when going into these
sort of tactical lines to have a few
different
options now okay now I could play Knight
G5 but I think I'll just start with
recapturing on
C3 and yeah what's Happening Here I
um I won back the piece pawns are still
equal yeah cuz black W C3 I won
H7 but Black's King is a bit more
exposed F6 is looking to get rid of this
Pawn if I take the queen can come
in I've also o spent a lot of time
already
so um I might want to play a bit more
intuitively going forward here I mean I
could go full attack with like H4 H5 I
could also
Castle castling is still probably safest
approach for for my king I think I will
Castle
here just be a bit more patient with the
attack if black takes on E5 then then I
can throw a knight
G5 we see D6 okay so a lot of attackers
against
E5 um yeah this is probably a smart
approach from
black trying to get me to take so the
queen can come
in I'm considering Bishop A3
here I'm not sure if I want to commit
the bishop to that diagonal
a move like Rook E1 just
supporting the E Pawn also Bishop
F4 I'm also thinking like yeah takes and
then develop the bishop and just try
and um complete development get the
Rooks into Play Let's Go for
this if the Rook takes I have the skewer
if the queen
takes uh yeah let's get the bishop in
connecting the
Rooks and this is a the main open file
that I like to control like rookie one
most likely coming
next I will say though that my
opponent's been playing well from what
seemed to be a tricky situation the
opening seems like they have a very
playable position here but I'm going to
be focusing on just optimizing the
pieces moving a bit quicker
not threatening Rook E7 right away
because uh Knight is controlling that
square um but D5 I guess D5 Queen digs
D5 so what to
do and Rook E8 is likely
coming we're going to play Bishop H4
this is
um basically a clearance move it has a
few purposes it is
defending F2 so the N is no longer like
pinned to the pawn and I'm also setting
up Knight to
G5 would be nice to get the knight in to
harass the king and this is a downside
of black just having the pawn here no
neighboring pawns this G5 square is in
my my full control and if I do get the
check
in it's going to be a question where the
king moves I'm going to start with this
King moves to this diagonal then then D5
could come with
check if it moves up to
H6 which is actually probably a safe
Square for
it now D5 I really want to Gambit the
pawn but I'm not seeing the followup
after Queen diges
D5 I could play something like Queen
D2 to align with the
King yeah let's go for although Queen D2
there's uh Queen F4
yeah Queen F4 is actually very strong
there okay change the plans I'm going to
play Rook D1 just centralizing if takes
I don't think I mind
trading Bishop is the bishop does look a
little bit overworked here but it's
covering F2 and
G5 I don't think black can exploit that
immediately
I would really like to exploit this King
somehow oh okay the king is trying to
exploit me King H5 what a move showing
no fear trying to take the
bishop I'm getting very low on time too
so um maybe just moving the Knight
back yeah defending just trying to be
solid uh blocking the battery
too and now I'm very very inclined to
punish this King somehow like H3
G4 maybe somehow sneak my queen
in Pawn
G5 black is throwing the kitchen sink at
me I think I can just take this
Pawn cuz yeah the Knight supports the
bishop and now there's really not much
shelter for the
king we see Rook
G8 I'm going to play
H4 cementing the bishop here the bishop
is very nice and just blocking the rook
and it's so hard for black to remove
now I mean the thing about this
construction is it's a bit hard to get
to the black
king cuz these pieces they don't attack
the king and they um yeah they make it
difficult for my other pieces to get
in so it might require some patience
here but also some
speed below 90
seconds so what is my game plan probably
getting my queen to a more useful spot
like a queen's not really doing anything
on
C3 maybe yeah maybe a bit more
centralize like Queen
E3 this bishop wants to come
here let's start with Queen
E3 some idea of Queen
E2 I'm also thinking Knight
H2 which is now threatening Pawn to
G4 have a nice nice backwards move
there's also the idea to maneuver the
Knight to F1 and then to
G3 cuz with the Knight on F3 it looked
good supporting these things
but sometimes when you have a dark squar
Bishop you also want your knight on a
dark Square so it controls light
squares uh King G6 I'm not getting my
Fork do I want to
expand let's go for Knight
F1 yeah I I like the prospect of getting
the Knight to G3
I'm below a minute now
so yeah I have to uh really watch my
time and these these games in the
speedrun have been getting more
difficult I think the the previous
episode as well I got down to around 30
seconds towards the end of the
game um I do have to be careful here of
the G2 pawn and queen G4 would threat
Checkmate but yeah the knight's very
good in defending
now it seems like I'm getting closer to
creating some mating
attack I'm going to kick this Knight
away something like Queen D3 is a move I
want to play I'll be honest I didn't
even see this move Knight C2 but uh yeah
this is a nice double attack black has
no time to take the
Rook can take the
knights
I'm just realizing I I had Rook E7 I I
should have looked for the the stronger
move there but uh yeah let's let's go
for the attack Knight F
five get the pieces in if King here I'll
have the
fork and it's important I may Luft for
my
king because yeah after Rook takes the
King has a
square um but now yeah looks like force
checkmates Bishop H6 will come and 28
seconds to spare so very hard fought
game uh kudos to my opponent for I think
being very resourceful out of the
opening in the early middle game um they
were very creative with their play too
like marching their King up trying to
attack thems on the king's side I think
it took some precise moves there to deal
with the
position so yeah just going forward here
here I mean I thought that uh I was
going to have a an easy time out of the
opening um especially
here and yeah Bishop takes H7 it was
based on a slight miscalculation like I
wanted to play Knight G5 initially but
Queen G5 would have just been much
better for black so it's good that I
realized that early enough yeah
sometimes when you go for these
sacrifices you really have to just
double check to make sure
that you're not missing um responses
from your
opponents so fortunately I was able to
win back the
Knight and going forward from
here yeah maybe there are some
improvements but trying to play
solidly King H5 I really wanted to
punish this move it's crazy that the the
engine here says the best move for white
is Knight H7
which looks completely ridiculous I mean
it does Hit The Rook but it seems like
yeah the knights and the bishop are now
attacked now stockfish wants to play H3
to just prepare this move so it's uh
yeah not a human sequence to to play for
white but yeah um I mean I just tried to
make sure everything was under
control and I like this maneuver to get
the Knight to G3
to compliment the
bishop and then yeah then black kind of
put the Knight on a vulnerable square
and when the king is so open like this
then yeah tactics are bound to happen so
if black were to play this then I was
still probably going to continue with
this move and then yeah assuming the
king moves back the Knight can come in
um still would have had very uh very
powerful attacking chances
here so um yeah good game a slightly
stressful game I think we'll end it
there uh thanks everyone for watching if
you have questions leave them below if
you like the content subscribe it does
help the channel grow and stay tuned for
more I'll see you guys soon